- Absolutely not.
- What is that?
(laughs)
(jazz music)
- Wet furs?
I don't know it's really weird.
- Smells like an old man's breath.
(jazz music)
- Oh boy.
Umm, it's sort of,
oh Jesus Christ.
Oh that is repulsive.
Oh my god.
(grunts)
- It looks like Nutella,
but like a shit version.
- Bon apetite.
- This looks like, like
if this came out of you,
you'd have to go to a hospital.
- Why is this a thing that people eat?
- Absolutely not.
- It's some kind of
guff butter.
(laughs)
- It's rank.
- What in the fuck?
(laughs)
- I never want that ever again.
- No, it's not good.
- No absolutely not.
- It tastes like old people.
- It's sort of like camembert, but bad.
- I don't know.
- No, feel like
zero interaction with that
after this, ever again.
- I once accidentally put salt in my tea
instead of sugar.
(laughs)
It tastes exactly like that.
(jazz music)